[Music]
well greetings good friends thank you
for joining us for our question and
answer program I'd like to know as
probably many of you know this is a
program where you send us your questions
we do the research and then attempt to
answer the questions on social media and
on television we appreciate you sending
us your questions you know sometimes
it's a real challenge because they are
questions we've never heard before
dealing with issues that we've never
researched before so we learn in the
process along with you so keep the
questions coming and remember that we
receive them in order and we answer them
in order I have with me uh my dear
friend here at Secrets unsealed he's in
charge of our Spanish work here at uh
our television channels social media
Pastor Salasar uh he's going to
participate in the program today and I
want to give you the electronic address
where you can send your questions you'll
see it on the screen
TVM tv.org once again
TVM tv.org r g we'd be delighted to
receive your questions now before we
actually begin to answer the questions
that we have for today we want to have a
word of prayer as we always do amen and
so I want to ask Pastor Salasar if he
would pre please pray that the Lord will
bless our program absolutely let's pray
Heavenly Father we are so thankful that
we can come to you to your throne of
grace and ask in the name of Jesus your
son for the holy spirit so that we may
receive the instruction the power of um
from on high and that we may be able to
share from your word answers that will
bring people closer to you and to a
clear understanding of the scriptures we
pray for this blessing in Jesus name
amen
amen okay we have a very interesting
question to start out today it comes
from David
M uh he lives in Oxnard
California and uh this is what uh he
sent us hello again pastors I immensely
enjoy your program and look forward to
when they are posted on
YouTube uh count my vote for expanding
it to an hourlong presentation wow my
question deals with the Ark of the
Covenant in the early part of Samuel's
ministry as you know the Israelites
unwisely and without God's blessing took
it into battle against the
Philistines the Israelites were routed
and the philis captured the ark the
Philistines after being plagued severely
returned it the Israelites who first
came upon it at Beth shemes mishandled
it causing a great destruction
eventually the Levites came and carried
it to kirth
jerim uh to the house of abinadab where
I believe it remained until David
brought it to
Jerusalem my question is simple
why was it not returned to Shiloh where
the Tabernacle was very simple question
thank you and it's a good question I
believe that it's one that probably many
students of the Bible had had when they
come to the you know understanding why
was not the ark returned to Shiloh well
the Bible speaks very little after the
experience of Eli and the Ark there in
Shiloh however it does bring us a very
clear understanding in the book of
Jeremiah chapter 7 12- 14 as to why the
the the ark was not returned and of
course I also then I'll add wording from
Spirit prophecy that gives us this uh
clear indication of why he did not
return to Silo but to Shiloh but notice
what says there in Jeremiah 71 12-14
this is actually centuries after and
notice what the Bible says it says there
but go ye now unto my place which was in
Shiloh where I said my name at the first
and see what I did to it for the
wickedness of My People
Israel and now because you have done all
these Works said the Lord and I spake
unto you raising up early and speaking
but he heard not and I called you but he
answer not therefore will I do unto this
house which is called by my name wherein
you trust and unto the place which I
gave to you and to your fathers as I
have done to Shiloh so here the Prophet
Jeremiah is speaking that whatever
happened to shyo in the past would
happen again for the the hardness of
their hearts because they did not
understand or go back to the Lord or
they not return to his ways now the
spirit of Prophecy in page uh 5 514 of
the p and Prophets it actually tells us
why did it not happen why did chot was
not again the place of the Ark it says
the ark remained at Shiloh for 300 years
until because of the sins of Eli's house
it fell into the hands of the
Philistines and Shiloh was ruined the
ark was never returned to the Tabernacle
here the sanctuary service was finally
transferred to the temple at Jerusalem
and Shiloh fell into
insignificance there are only ruins to
Mark the spot where he once stood so
this is the reason the because of the
sins of Eli's house because of the
apostasy of the House of Eli Shiloh
became a place of Ruin and became a
warning in the in the future what to
what would happen to the Temple of the
Lord and as we know the temple was
utterly destroyed because again as in
the time of uh of the of the Israelites
they did not understood or they not
follow the warning they did not learn
from shot's mistake and they repeat it
again by rejecting Christ so this is why
and it was taken to
Jerusalem because
ultimately the temple built by Solomon
was going to be the resting place for
the ark right uh Shiloh had the
Tabernacle mhm and the Tabernacle was
only a provisional thing a tent as they
moved through the Wilderness but then uh
when David established the kingdom then
the temple was going to be rebuilt by
Solomon his son and then the ark and
everything else was going to rest within
the city of Jerusalem mhm
exactly okay well thank you for that
question uh you know I had never heard
that question before yeah but uh it's
very interesting it increases our
knowledge now the next question is from
Tanzania from
maias and uh it says this greetings from
Tanzania Ellen White writes Christ Bears
the penalty for man's past
transgressions and by imparting to man
his righteousness makes it possible for
man to keep God's holy law MH is it
correct to say that this righteousness
that Christ imparts to man to make it
possible for him to keep the law is the
new
birth so is the New Birth the imparted
righteousness of Christ or does Christ
impart his righteousness because we have
experienced a new birth well I I will
let you answer this question a little
more but I will give you a response from
spir prophecy that speaks of what you
know sometimes what we try to figure out
what exactly is righteousness by faith
and and and what not in the book faith
that I live by Page
116 uh she writes this the righteousness
by which we are Justified is imputed the
righteousness by which we are Sanctified
is imparted the first is our title to
heaven the second is our fitness for
heaven many commit their error of trying
to define mutely the fine points of
distinction between justification and
sanctification into the definitions of
these two terms they often bring their
own ideas and speculations why try to be
more minute than its inspiration on the
vital question of righteousness by faith
as a penan sinner contrive before God
discerns Christ atonement in his behalf
and accepts this atonement as his only
hope in this life and in the future life
his sins are pardoned this is
justification by faith and then
satification is not the work of a moment
an hour a day but of a lifetime is not
gained by a happy fight of feeling a
flight of feeling rather but is the
result of constantly dying to sin and
constantly living for Christ so I I
think that you know she specifies here
that stif justification by faith is this
experience of accepting Christ and his
atonement for sin is that believe and
it's part of of course is part of the
new birth experience is is is is that
but I think it's both it's not just the
fact of accepting the imput rightous of
Christ but also having that in part that
power to overcome the power to obey so I
I don't know if I could you know Define
it really to the fact of saying is it
rightous by faith the same thing as new
birth of course it is it's part of it
but it's also that power that is asking
about you know the power to make it to
keep the law in that experience so I
believe it's is is one uh as at all you
know is both is both aspects together
yeah um you know I'm interested in that
statement of Ellen White where she says
uh she speaks about the imputed
righteousness and imparted righteousness
right before that quotation which comes
from review heral June 4 1895 the
original Source MH it says righteousness
within is testified by righteousness
without
mhm he who is righteous
within is not hard-hearted and
unsympathetic but day by day he grows
into the image of Christ going on from
strength to
strength he who is being Sanctified by
the truth will be self-controlled and
will follow in the footsteps of Christ
until Grace is lost in glory mhm uh and
then of course comes the quotation the
righteousness by which we are Justified
is imputed you know that word imputed is
a theological word it means credited to
our account MH it means simply that I
don't have it in my account and Christ
takes it and credits it to my account
without any without any Merit without it
without deserving it yes he takes his
righteousness and he places it to my
account and I'm looked upon as if I had
never sinned but at the same moment God
is not going to justify anyone who is
not willing to be Sanctified abely and
in order to live a Sanctified life you
have to be born again you have to be
have been regenerated exactly which the
question deals with this specific point
uh you know does uh the imparting his
righteousness make it possible to keep
God's holy law uh the answer is yes but
you have to be born again exactly and so
you know it's very very dangerous to
make uh definite distinction between
imputed righteousness and imparted
righteousness imputed righteousness is
the root and imparted righteousness is
the fruit right um you know and we know
what Jesus said about the tree that had
no fruit right yeah it had root it had
lots of leaves but it didn't have the
fruit right and so uh the conversion
experience is an experience that
includes uh Jesus taking his
righteousness and putting it to our
account which is made manifest by
keeping the Commandments of God you know
I've been involved in the last few
sermons that I preached for Sabbath
morning here sequence unsealed a series
on righteousness by faith and you know
people get all caught up in the 1888
message you know that that becomes uh
sometimes even their gospel exactly
that's all they can talk about and uh
you know they I think they complicate
matters because Ellen White simply says
it's faith in the shity yes faith and
the shity the shity means the one who
takes our place faith in the shity which
is made manifest right by obedience to
all the Commandments of God so it's a
package deal like you were mentioning
yeah it's not one or the other it's not
uh one uh you know versus the other
correct but it's actually a package deal
where justification leads to a
Sanctified life in this her Ages page
300 she says this both are titled To
Heaven and are Fitness for for it are
found in the righteousness of Christ so
it's it's again you know it's trying to
Define as you mentioned Pastor trying to
you know be minute in into figuring
exactly this is what it is I think it's
trying to complicate matters instead of
make it more simple you know a
requirement that new bir experience new
new life in Christ in order to make it
to Heaven it's not enough to have the
title yeah you have to have the fitness
Fitness to it yes uh the title is
justification the fitness is life that
comes as a result yeah uh so you
know it's not rocket science but some
people over focus on justification and
they say that that your life doesn't
really matter because you already have
the title to heaven and that is not
correct in harmony with God's will
absolutely okay now we have another one
M uh this is uh from Owen it doesn't say
where he's writing from uh I am blessed
with your program please continue well
well by God's grace we will we try I
have a question amen why did Paul appeal
to Emperor Nero for his trial wasn't he
disadvantaging himself knowing that Nero
was a cruel man who did not support
religion or its
Advocates so so why did he appeal to
Nero when he knew the type of person
that Nero was that's the question that's
the question well the we know that in
Acts of the Apostles p uh chapter
25 when he Paul appeals to Caesar he was
before fesus and he appeals to Caesar
there's a reason why he appeals to
Caesar not that he really wanted to go
to Neo necessarily but there was this
issue notice what it says there in verse
7 of Acts
25 and when he was come speaking of uh
Paul the Jews which came down from
Jerusalem stood around about and laid
many and Grievous complaints against
Paul which they could not
prove while he answered for himself
neither against the law of the Jews
neither against the temple not yet
against Caesar have I offended anything
at all but fesus notice what happens
he's Paul is showing that he has nothing
to Def you know that he's has he has
violated from the laws of the land or
even from the Jews himself but notice
verse 9 but fesus willing to do the Jews
a pleasure answered Paul and said will
thou go up to Jerusalem and there be
judged on these things before me so FES
saying you know why don't we just go to
Jerusalem and have the meeting
there then verse 10 Paul said Paul I
stand at caar judgment seat where I
ought to be judge to the Jews have I
done no wrong and thou very well as thou
very well knowest so here here Paul
realizes that with fesus trying to
please the Jews taking him to Jerusalem
was basically a a a dead sentence for
him he knew the fact now spir prophecy
of course says that and and I want to
read it from acts Apostles page 430 this
is the book of Acts of the Apostles by L
white 430 it says this the Apostle knew
that he could not look for Justice from
the people who by their crimes were
bringing down upon themselves the rod of
God he knew knew that like the Prophet
Elijah he will be safer among the
heathens than with those who had
rejected the life from heaven and
heartened their hearts against the
gospel weary of strife his active Spirit
could not ill endure the repeated delays
and wearing suspense of his trial and
imprisonment he therefore decided to
exercise his privilege as a Roman
citizen of appealing to Caesar and then
in in this uh fourth paragraph of the
same book uh the same page it says that
it was done once more because of hatred
born of vicotry and self-righteousness a
servant of God was driven to turn for
protection to the Heathen it was the
same hatred that forced the Prophet
Elijah to flee for sucer to the Widow of
s cerea and that forced the Heralds of
the Gospel to turn from the Jews to
proclaim the message to the Gentiles and
this hatred of the people of God living
in the age have yet to meet so he's
saying again because of the hatred of
the Jews hatred of of towards the truth
to the Servants of God he had to go for
protection to the Heathen so he appealed
to
Caesar based on the fact that had he
gone to the Jews they would have killed
him and he felt that the impression of
God was to go to Cesar and appeal to him
and give him more time to spread the
gospel and to speak for the truth so at
the end um it was better for him to go
to Nero even though he was a wicked men
as We Know Than to go and to stay within
the Judgment of of the Jerusalem
authorities yeah Ellen White and Acts of
the Apostles 486 and 487 MH um really
indicates that it was wise for him to go
before Nero yeah not only because the
Jews would have tried him and condemned
him to death but I think for two two
other reasons and Ellen White mention is
one of them uh from the Viewpoint of
human judgment she says Paul's
condemnation before such a judge was
certain other words they felt if he goes
to Nero yeah he's a dead man right but
the Apostle felt that so long as he was
loyal to God he had nothing to fear the
one who in the past had been his
protector could Shield him still from
the malice of the Jews and from the
power of Caesar MH and God did Shield
his servant amen at Paul's examination
the charges against him were not
sustained and and contrary to the
general expectation and with a regard
for justice wholly at variance with his
with his character Nero declared the
prisoner Guiltless Paul's Bonds were
removed he was again a free man I guess
it was pretty wise for him to appeal to
Nero because he was released and the
first time yeah the second reason which
Ellen White does not mention
specifically here is that in the day of
judgment we know that Nero is going to
be outside the holy city absolutely
Ellen White on the last chapter of great
controversy makes it clear that he's
outside the city his mother is there too
that brought taught him to be the way
that he was and he's not going to be
able to say to the Lord I never knew had
no light I I had no light I had no
knowledge and God is going to say
remember when Paul stood before you and
you declared him Guiltless and you saw
the Holiness of his character I tried to
reach you I did everything I could but
you extinguish the light mhm and so uh
we are never to question the wisdom of
God how God does things or we're not to
question the wisdom of Paul in making an
appeal to to Nero uh and by the way the
book of Acts doesn't mention Paul's uh
appearance before Nero I know it's Ellen
White mentions it but the scripture does
not mention that he actually really did
appeal and appear before Nero to present
his case although the Christian um you
know history historians do mention that
he did appear to her and it was was the
second time that he appeared to that he
was killed yeah unfortunately Chris
there's are many Christian Traditions
that that are reliable yeah of course uh
you know like for example uh the book of
um well nowhere in the Bible do we find
that uh the Apostle John was thrown into
cauldron of boiling oil ex Ellen White
confirms it she says he was thrown in
but and God did the same with uh with
John as he did with Shadrach Michigan
Abednego of course uh but that's Ellen
White is being simply a tradition a very
reliable tradition of what occurred to
John actually before the emperor doiss
exactly so
yeah okay so that's uh I hope that
that's a um reliable answer to the
question MH um now we have another
question uh and this one has to do with
um a practical matter it has to do with
financial management right and I'm not
sure that we have enough time right now
left left for this program to be able to
deal with this specific uh with this
specific issue uh it's interesting the
person who is sending us this U question
uh her name is Tesha and and her email
is prodical
daughter very very interesting beautiful
but but that means that she came home
mhm amen hallelujah amen for that all
right uh so what I want to do maybe for
the next couple of minutes is um you
know speak about the importance of uh
receiving the questions absolutely from
those who watch our program uh you know
we feed on you when you send us your
questions it forces us uh and I use the
word forces in quotation marks it forces
us to go to the Bible and investigate
things that we never actually thought of
mhm it's amazing some of the questions
that we receive I don't know if you feel
the same way that I absolutely Pastor
there's many questions that we have had
that I thought wow this is something
that I've never looked at this way or
have not questioned myself and it's
important because it allows us to really
study more the word of God and see what
things can be said now sometimes these
questions are also a reflection of how
much people are studying the scriptures
which is a real blessing it really
encourages us to know people are
studying the scriptures which is what we
want people to do we want to encourage
them to study the scripture and and to
me this is really what allows us to know
the the difference that the ministry is
making in in people's lives and some
questions stump
us you know definitely some questions
that people ask you say I wonder whether
there really is an answer to this
question in the Bible in the spirit of
Prophecy and we can't find it and of
course when we can't find uh an answer
to the question we have to tell people
you know we don't really know there's
nothing wrong with us saying that we
don't really know yeah uh it it's food
for thought and we do more research
another point that I want to bring out
is that we do appreciate the prayers of
all of those who support Secrets
unsealed in some TV yeah uh we could not
do anything in this ministry without the
prayer warriors that are out there uh we
also appreciate uh the donations that
people give to Secrets unsealed TV us to
be in the a it's very expensive to uh do
program like this it takes a lot of
personnel it takes a lot of equipment uh
but many many people write to us and
tell us that what we produce here is a
great blessing to them and so we
encourage you to continue praying that
God will use this ministry to reach the
world with the present truth and if you
are able to also contribute financially
to the operations of Secrets unsealed
and some TV so that we can continue to
reach the world God bless you thank you
for joining us and till next time our
program I'd like to know
[Music]